thanks for being here thanks for having
me oh of course yeah yeah
congratulations things are going so well
for you thank you yeah you know i i
don't want to be i mean you you look
fantastic i was a little hurt when you
shifted from being a redhead to a blonde
because there's only like there are very
few of us there was you there's me and
there's elmo yeah it's like
and like ralph mel from happy days
there's like nobody almost a different
red exactly
yeah but i mean you know so i was i took
it personally i thought that you thought
hey redheads that's not the way to go
you know sorry yeah it's for a movie
role right so i will be back to red you
will be back well that's nice that's
nice for me cause i remember we had
actually your the doll you're this is a
doll i guess that's a big seller this is
a doll of you it looks a lot like me
yeah well you don't think so it's very
nice
similar yeah this is so that's like
really bright bright bright bright
bright bright red because the doll that
we sell here at the nbc store bright
bright bright bright bright look at that
this is the conan doll
this has sort of an orange
do you think they should hold hands my
doll's too shy
my dog my dog
yeah my doll's like ah she doesn't like
me
get back here conan no
i have acne um
press a button and mine breaks out it's
really sad but you're gonna be back
you're gonna come back which is good
yeah now
so much has happened you know uh in your
life in the last two years it's all good
you've had so much success you have to
adjust to this tabloid thing yeah which
is we all know is getting out of hands
and sometimes you now you pick up the
tabloids and you learn things about
yourself is that right i you know it's
it's really funny i just was reading the
paper yesterday and um
it said i was dating someone
and it was secretive for two months and
i'm completely in love and now i'm
engaged right it's not true right right
but still do you ever like read it
quickly and go like wow who is this guy
you know this is uh yeah yeah it happens
all the time you think like this sounds
like a good idea it's kind of sick yeah
yeah
i just want to be in the tabloids i
don't care what i have to do i walk
around naked they're like nah we're not
interested uh
maybe the naked thing isn't helping me
um maybe maybe that's what it is is it
hard for you now i would think like if
you just want to meet somebody you know
they might be intimidated by you because
you've become such a big star do you
know what i mean i don't that's so
strange to me yeah yeah i'm very normal
i'm very honest i do have a very strong
personality right maybe a little too
honest sometimes right right um but do
you ever think there's probably like
some nice guys out there that would be
intimidated because of the success
you've had like well i can't go up to
her i would hope not yeah i'm i'm i'm a
very open person i'm more than willing
to okay we're not talking to this
audience here by the way
guys are starting to line up in the in
the
uh now i read that i don't know if this
is true someone raised their hand yeah
that shows a lot of confidence i don't
care i'm here at a tv taping i'm going
for it
you know just why not
god love that guy
it's not happening
um i love you too sir uh
oh he meant you oh i'm sorry
you uh i read that you scare easily is
that true i give i get scared very
easily please don't scare me
i'm sorry i can be very scary i'm sorry
is that true
you you do scary like you can't go to a
scary movie or anything no i love scary
movies okay um but i get scared very
easily i can be staring at someone and
they like you just did
well people are very frightened of me
often i can look kind of insane i'm
asked to sleep right because i'm afraid
i get freaked out sometimes right i've i
i just i don't know you know what my
wife hates when i turn to her really
slowly she can't stand it like
yeah i don't like that
you're freaking me
no i'm sorry
isn't it weird though i know what your
doll looks like yeah it's like
my doll can do it too i can get my doll
to turn real get tight and then slowly
um complete with creepy turn it says on
the box
well let's talk about something happy
then rather than you getting scared your
birthday's coming up july 2nd do you
know you're gonna have a big blowout you
know what you're gonna do um i'm gonna
be working but i think um i'll try and
make it either new york or la and
make sure my family comes out um and you
know i'll get together with some friends
right do something right
so you like birthday some people don't
like you know like the cake and happy
but you know some people don't like that
they i it's weird because i'm a
performer i like to be out in front of
people but whenever people do too yeah
exactly but but this is the thing when
people are bringing you a cake and
everyone's looking at you that's when i
get shy i don't know about you but
that's when i'm like don't look at me
yeah it's a weird thing the pressure's
on everyone's looking at you and waiting
for you to i'm always nervous that i'm
not going to be able to blow all the
candles out on the cake this is my
secret i just wipe them off
i don't really recommend then i say
everybody out really angrily
do you like the the nickname so people
are always trying to you know like give
you nicknames do you ever notice that
like you know ello or something like
that do you does that stuff make you
laugh or i never had one of those i'm
like see rat or something i've never
but is there a do you ever do like those
when people come up with um yeah yeah
they're kind of fun why not my friends
call me all sorts of things right right
mine too but they're not
but they're not pleasant ditto yeah uh
okay let's talk about irby fully loaded
there's a lot of driving in this movie
fully like that's it i do the
to me the hs
yeah i do the h is silent herby isn't
that nice
herbie
it's like herbs and spices
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get america
saying it my way but uh are you a good
driver um yeah yeah i wasn't with the
paparazzi and yeah i heard about that
incident that's unpleasant yeah um
but yeah i'm a good driver i had to take
nascar lessons and i went to um the
richard petty driving school that is so
cool um which was really fun how fast
how fast can you go on the track we i
wasn't driving when we went we went like
90 195
when i did 195 190 i'm exaggerating
yeah
after like 120 it doesn't matter you
know it's like but that's so cool and i
was freaking out and i started to i was
i almost started crying i was shaking
right because they get really close to
the walls and that you if i mean if you
do this with the wheel you're off the
tracks and you're done for right right i
think that would be very scary it was
scary but it was fun it's it's very
exhilarating yeah i would think so
people say that you can actually you
know feel like you're just living on the
edge when you go that fast i've never
done that i get up to like 60 and that's
it
when you have if you i i i like cars and
i have a fast car um and you know when
you have a fest car you don't drive it
as fast i think as you think you will
right right well a lot of times you
can't yeah a lot of times they say like
they so someone buys a fast car they're
like this thing goes up to 240 and like
are you where are you going where are
you going with this car where can you
drive that in the world
especially for guys right knowing it's
there is kind of cool
which is where my ford taurus comes in
it's really loaded uh
now you're gonna get like five free four
tauruses exactly that's total total
value of sixty thousand dollars
hey sorry ford uh
well i've mentioned it a lot and they
never sent one so i had to get them back
we have a clip here from i call it irby
but you say herbie uh from herbie fully
loaded what do we need to know about
this clip um i believe this clip is um
i just graduated from college my
father's taking me to get me a car and
he takes me to a junkyard to get a car
cool um and uh this is where i meet
herbie irby
see i've got you doing it now let's take
a look at this clip
[Music]
[Music]
nothing's calling out to me
oh now trust me there is a certified
pre-owned champion out there just
waiting here
[Music]
it's perfect okay just think if this
horn hadn't gone off i wouldn't have
found this nissan
making you feel like the car is alive
you know
uh
you really have a bomb yeah
you really feel like the car is alive
that's why you can get confused uh
herbie fully loaded is in theaters right
now thanks so much for stopping by thank
you yeah nice to see you lindsay lohan
david allen's here coming up and take a
break
you